did you watch Last of Us yeah hey if you
like the last of us and you don't want
it spoiled then skip to 21 minutes and
55 seconds
the how [__] good was that last
episode hack that dude's face though
dude that dude made my skin crawl yeah
yeah even in the beginning where you
weren't really sure you know they didn't
make it clear that he was a shitty guy
yeah
in the beginning
sorry I'm sorry all right
yeah no continue continue just like in
the beginning like you know they weren't
really you know he was like the leader
of this group seemed like he was being
nice yeah
and
but there was just something off about
him you know yeah just Eerie I well then
he turned out to be a cannibal
what and you're like oh yeah brutal
combo brutal combo dude
different kind of CP seriously
that's a tough combo well I thought okay
in the beginning when
um
when he was being all weird
I thought he was going to make them do a
Jim Jones thing like a group Suicide or
something yeah like when he's like I got
to make sure you're still with me right
but so we got the cult Vibe and I'm
thinking spoiler alert by the way
yeah they yeah sorry spoiler alert
everyone in The Last of Us dies
yeah
um no but yeah yeah no I I so I no it's
the same because it felt kind of culty
yeah but I thought they did a good job
of
you know well when you saw the ear
you're like uh oh they're cannibals I
didn't pick that up when I saw the ear
right I was like oh they killed someone
in here oh wait speaking of ears that
guy looked like Van Gogh
yeah he did yeah yeah you're right
when the ear happened I thought oh they
eat people
so I'm thinking Canada I was like that's
somebody's ear on the ground yeah that's
all I thought
that's the only thing I thought
she what's her name again
yeah Ellie yeah yeah she makes a
connection right away yeah I didn't
you're just like oh I was like what's
she so it's an ear you're in jail in the
[__] cult this is a [__] Airline
on the ground you're just in the moment
kind of guy yeah exactly you just take
it as it comes I'm not thinking too far
ahead yeah behind that's just the ear
yeah
I could hear you in that scenario
oh somebody oh they eat people
oh literally I thought that was just an
ear I think Ellie's actually like
literally says you guys are eating
people and I was like ah
I thought somebody just dropped their
ear
oops
no when um
when he smacked the [__] out of that kid
and then he said you'll always have a
father
right before he did that
in my mind I jokingly said
like as if I'm him Daddy's upset okay
and then when you said you always have a
father I went um
kind of getting P Vibes right here oh I
thought it was still more like uh this
is a cult I'm Your Leader type [__] well
I but I guess those kind of go hand in
hand I felt you know well after when he
when he was like I want the girl alive
yeah you know okay yeah thinking kind of
got some inventory going on yeah why
yeah yeah you know because everyone's
like
I feel like in a survival situation you
know the kids are
not fun they're probably gonna die yeah
okay you know
this is another mouth to feed you you
got to make some hard decisions and the
fact that he's like no no keep all the
little girls right
and let me ask you this what what in
that that shot of them eating in the
dining hall when they're like what is
this and it's like it's venison was it
venison or was it that was people
and they're all like going after it too
yeah I just thought it was like because
they're hungry but they're all like
they'll get that like cannibal bloodlust
that was pretty uh
isn't that what it's CBO thing isn't it
like one Taste Of The Forbidden meat
yeah CBL dude you know it's supposed to
be the best
I don't think that's true
or it might be true I think that happens
with
um murder what
uh people in military talk about that
like once you kill them if they kill
then you want to do it again yeah what
yeah really yeah it's like a weird thing
ugh yeah sorry I had to take it to a
dark that is dark as hell
that is so dark
you saw a clip of the Marine talking
about how after he shot someone he just
wanted to do it over and over
yo mom can you come pick me up
uh mom the world broke out again he's
saying weird stuff
and this is not fun anymore he's making
us watch weird YouTube videos we were
watching planet Earth at first and it
was all good
no watching Marine testimony interview
yeah Navy SEAL testimonials
I thought we were listening to Rogan it
was just a marine talking about shooting
people you should be a family man I just
want to kill all the time yo isn't this
crazy
sucks yo check out this guy Chris Kyle
[Laughter]
yeah good ass episode though when she
when she hacked his head open yeah I
like how long they let it go it was like
I know it was really good I'm like oh
yeah I'm like kill him you know what I'm
bummed they didn't show his head yeah
there's one reverse shot real quick yeah
just yeah looking like a diced onion
yeah it just completely Fallen open
is that venison yeah and then it would
have been the ultimate Revenge if she
took a bite yeah yeah just took a little
piece of his brain just
then she runs out and eats Joel yeah I
guess she's got the blood pressure she
got the CBO the cannibal BL dude I need
the more I need more of the Forbidden
man he's a forbidden meat you know what
the shots of the body's hanging up were
that was that was pretty brutal yeah it
was good I got me I liked it what
I'd say like that I liked it I wanted to
be there
a guy like me would have been like is
this human
they're like no it's venison I'd be like
oh
wait sorry I wanted to say the sound
design in that scene when they were like
going in was pretty good like the rapid
fire of the spoons hitting the poles but
two like [__] and it was good though
yeah it was really good so again like
something just felt like off you're like
oh they're wolf in there it's like do I
mean there must and then you're like
well they're hungry they've been they're
all like literally starving so I kind of
get it yeah they keep talking about like
rations and how hard it is to feed
everyone so I'm like okay they're going
it's venison [__] good and then you
saw the ear and you just didn't get it
and then I saw the ear and I was like so
somebody dropped their [__] ear
I don't know he must have been hungry
they dropped their [__] ear on the
ground I don't know didn't even realize
I didn't know elk ears got that big yeah
exactly I feel like Ellie's character
kind of like blossomed
in the last like couple episodes oh yeah
I feel like I wasn't really like
enjoying her acting maybe sure or
something but I think that's what
or maybe it was like the chemistry
between her and
I don't know but now it's like finally I
don't know I feel like this show has
been kind of uh
like the first episode was super like
intense and then it's kind of been a
slow burn ever since but it's it's
getting really [__] good yeah at
first I thought
um uh Bella Ramsay's performance was
annoying
but then I thought about it and I
thought
I think it's actually good performance
because kids are [__] annoying yeah
like they're really [__] annoying and
I mean especially a kid like that yeah
gift that's like raised after the
apocalypse yeah something is special
about her but no like no one understands
she didn't choose to be like one of the
special like the special one the one
that's supposed to save the Earth but
not only that even in her you know
military school
she's kind of a brat yeah just tough
yeah and all that stuff so yeah I think
yeah but I hear you on I agree
her her character was grating yeah just
everything was like ah [__]
but I think I think that's why it's good
because it's like
name one 12 year old that isn't like
really [__] annoying that's true yeah
yeah
that's a good point
I can't I can't again man one dude